anne baekeland la directrice adjointe du
groupement géré handicap à magny les
hameaux et à présent l invité du 7-8
bonsoir ça bienvenue sur ce plateau on
va évoquer une opération importante
elles concernent notamment le soutien
aux aidants et aux proches des personnes
atteintes de la maladie d'alzheimer par
dessus tête c'est lenoir spectacle de la
compagnie entrée de jeu et il parle de
cette problématique des aidants
représentation le 26 avril à 14h30 c'est
une pièce un peu particulière vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus oui bien
sûr alors le théâtre forum c'est une des
spécialités de cette compagnie entrée de
jeu qui effectivement écrit des pièces
organisé sous forme d'une succession de
saynètes et la particularité c'est que
c'est complètement en interaction avec
le public c'est à dire qu'à tout moment
le public peut interrompre la pièce et
se dire ah bah non c'est pas tout à fait
comme ça que moi j'aurais vu les choses
ce sont les aidant les personnes qui
sont aux côtés de alors les malades
d'alzheimer
là je donnais effectivement le principe
général de du théâtre forum et sur cette
pièce en particulier par dessus tête
c'est pour évoquer la problématique de
la fonction du proche qui accompagnent
au quotidien une personne qui a atteint
d'une pathologie alors dans le cadre de
cette pièce et la maladie d'alzheimer ça
peut être aussi bien sur une autre
pathologie
c'est pour effectivement évoqué toute la
difficulté de cet accompagnement au
quotidien et donc c'est aborder sous
forme de saynètes et le public donc
composé des dents mais aussi de sa
famille peut interrompre les saynètes et
les faire rejouer ou ajouter un
personnage et un fil rouge c'est
l'histoire d'un couple
victor jeanne la pièce aborde ces
plusieurs thèmes l'annnonce de la
maladie le quotidien la demande dès
l'entrée en établissement également
voilà ce sont des thématiques qui sont
joués dans cette dans cette pièce par
dessus tête mais ça va pouvoir
effectivement ouvrir sur un des
questions beaucoup plus large comment
gérer le quotidien qui est parfois
compliqué comment maintenir le lien
aussi qui nous unit à la personne qu'on
accompagne ce soit mère enfant perd
enfants ou conjoint tout simplement
et puis comment se préserver aussi quand
nas est fonction d' accompagner au
quotidien de cette fonction des dents
puisque c'est le terme qu'on utilise
très très très largement ça qu'ils
jugent donc ça s'adresse dans cette
famille ça s'adresse à la famille en
toute entière je dirais parce que quand
on est dans cette fonction d'accompagner
au quotidien qu'on est soi-même dans
l'organisation d'une vie familiale
on s'aperçoit qu'effectivement
accompagner au quotidien une personne
atteinte de la maladie d'alzheimer ou
d'autres pathologies
c'est prenant de plus en plus prenant
c'est préoccupant épuisant et que ça a
souvent un impact sur l'ensemble de la
famille parce que effectivement ça remet
en cause un petit peu l'euro la place de
chacun sa disponibilité pour le reste de
la famille qui est qui est impactée
effectivement un million de personnes et
touchée par cette maladie d'alzheimer
les chiffres sont plutôt en phase
ascendante c'est à dire qu'il y aura
deux autres plus en plus de malades il y
aura aussi de plus en plus de familles
concernées des dents également les
aidants qui sont ces et dont justement
quelle est leur quotidien ce ne sont pas
forcément des membres de la famille
alors c'est souvent est majoritairement
des membres de la famille très
majoritairement aussi des femmes soit
une fille qui s'occupe de sa mère de son
de son papa
c'est aussi la conjointe qui souvent
plus longtemps que son que son mari
c'est surtout cette fonction
effectivement à l'intérieur de la
famille mais ça peut être fait un voisin
ça peut être un ami
toute personne qui est proche
effectivement de la personne malade
quelles sont les plus grandes
difficultés qui sont rencontrés par ces
aidants justement alors baissé pouvoir
concilier quelquefois le travail et la
vie de famille et cette fonction
d'accompagnement quand c'est un enfant
par exemple qui accompagne un parent âgé
c'est assurer le quotidien sait
s'organiser c'est se préserver aussi et
surtout de se maintenir en bonne santé
car on sait que cette fonction d'aidant
épuise et que bas qu'il arrive au sein
d'un couple
par exemple que les dents souvent décède
avant même son parent malade
donc on sait que c'est une fonction qui
est extrêmement prenante épuisante et
que la fonction aussi de cette pièce est
de pouvoir aborder ces questions
sérieuses mais de manière aussi un peu
légère puisque c'est une pièce qui est
aussi qui se veut très conviviale ça
doit permettre de sortir de l'isolément
aussi bon c'est pour les aidants qui
parfois se sont peut-être justement tout
seul oui ça permet de partager
effectivement son quotidien ses
difficultés de pouvoir aussi faire appel
à caen quelqu'un a mis en place des
aides pouvoir s'appuyer sur des conseils
des aides
ça permet effectivement d'échangés de
rompre l'isolément dans lequel on peut
se sentir ou s'enfermer soi même quand
on est débordé donc ça permet tout ça
effectivement si la première a fait une
pièce de ce type de théâtre formé autour
de la maladie d'alzheimer est proposé
alors si c'est vertement gmc part mais
j'ai un handicap s'est associé tout
naturellement ce que je dois dire aussi
c'est que c'est une as you qui mené par
le comité départemental d'éducation pour
la santé avec des financements de
l'agencé régionale de santé qui
développe des projets justement des deux
aidants et c'est dans ce cadre là
effectivement que j'ai un handicap s'est
associé avec la ville de montigny qui
met à disposition une salle dans les
actions menées par le connaissent plus
généralement autour et des personnes
âgées et de l'aide aux aidants
donc c'est des actions qui sont de plus
en plus multipliez ça peut prendre cette
forme là ça peut prendre d'autres formes
auxquelles j'ai un handicap s'est
associé également puisque on va mener
mais ça on aura l'occasion peut-être à
un autre moment
d'en parler on va aussi organiser tout
un programme d'action des deux aidants
sous forme de café rencontre d'échangé
mais en ville dans la cité pour aussi
rompre cet isolement
ça va permettre attention particulière
portée aux aidants et voilà c'est
important parce que quelquefois il
décède alors avant avant les personnes
qu'ils accompagnent encore plus
difficile la situation de le quotidien
aussi pour pour les malades qui ensuite
se retrouve tout seul patient passe
d'épuissement effectivement de de la
personne qui la famille est le premier
relais effectivement et c'est toute la
difficulté aussi pas feint d'accepter de
se faire aider par des à l'extérieur
c'est toutes ces thématiques vont être
abordés également parce que parce que
les adore n'osent pas ils se disent moi
je ne suis pas malade qui peut-être
responsables ils se sentent aussi en
première place en tout cas pour
accompagner son propre site se sont en
capacité de le faire
il se sent dans cette fonction aussi de
deux d'être l'aidant principal et
et voilà c'est tout cette difficulté de
pouvoir aussi passer le relais et de se
préserver
vous mentionnez géré handicap gérant des
caps qu'on peut être préciser ce qu'est
ce bruit bien sûr alors géré handicap
c'est un groupe ont effectivement de
coopération qui réunit des acteurs
sociaux médico-sociaux sanitaires pour
mettre en synergie des compétences des
ressources et pour développer toute une
politique sociale et solidaire autour
des personnes en perte d'autonomie des
aidants familiaux et des situations de
handicap
on leur donne la date de cette
représentation 26 avril 14h30 par dessus
tête avec cette compagnie dans le cadre
d'un théâtre forum qui interviendra
réservation obligatoire mais c'est
gratuit république spectacle entièrement
gratuit puisque financé par la rs donc
entièrement gratuits ont demandé
réservation puisque les places sont
limitées de faire ses réservations
auprès de g handicap directement au 01
34 ans qu'elle se dirigeait vers ce site
internet aussi avec l'adresse mail pour
pouvoir pouvoir vous inscrire il ya
participé et ça c'est à montigny nas
appel celui salle gauguin pour les pour
les aidants pour les familles pour
l'entourage et pour tous ceux qui
voudraient aussi à en savoir un petit
peu plus sur l'aide qu'on peut apporter
à ces aidants de ces personnes atteintes
de la maladie d'alzheimer merci sphère
professionnelle également bien sûr c'est
pas fermée mais aussi aux aidants
professionnels
merci de ces précisions nous allons
bientôt refermée cette étude se 7,8 on
va faire un point sur l'actualité du
jour